in this video we're going to talk about
the volume of a pyramid and many of you
are might already be familiar with the
formula for the volume of a pyramid but
the goal of this video is to give us an
intuition or to get us some arguments as
to why that is the formula for the
volume of a pyramid so let's just start
by drawing ourselves a pyramid and I'll
draw one with a rectangular base but
depending on how we look at the formula
we can have a more general version but a
pyramid looks something like this
and you might get a sense of what the
formula for the volume of a pyramid
might be if we say this dimension right
over here is X this dimension right over
here the length right over here is Y and
then you have a height of this pyramid
if you were to go from the center
straight to the top
or you further measure this distance
right over here which is the height of
the pyramid you let's call that let's
call that Z and so you might say well
I'm I'm dealing with three dimensions so
maybe I multiply the three dimensions
together and that would give you volume
in terms of units but if you just
multiplied XY times Z that would give
you the volume of the entire rectangular
prism that contains the pyramid so that
would give you the volume of this thing
which is clearly bigger has a larger
volume than the pyramid itself the
pyramid is fully contained inside of it
so this would be the tip of the pyramid
on the surface just like that and so you
might get a sense that all right maybe
the volume of the pyramid is equal to x
times y times z times some constant and
what we're going to do in this video is
have an argument as to what that
constant should be assuming that this
the volume of the pyramid is roughly of
this structure and to help us with that
let's draw a larger rectangular prism
and break it up into six pyramids that
completely make up the volume of the
rectangular prism
so first let's imagine a pyramid that
looks something like this where its
width is X its depth is y so that could
be its base and its height is halfway up
the rectangular prism so if the
rectangular prism has height Z the
pyramids height is going to be Z over 2
now what would be the volume of that
pyramid based on what we just saw over
here
well that value would be equal to some
constant K times X times y naught times
Z times the height of the pyramid times
Z over 2 so it'd be x times y times Z
over 2 I'll just write times Z over 2 or
actually we can even write it this way X
Y is Z over 2 now I can construct
another pyramid has the exact same
dimensions if I were to just flip that
existing pyramid on its head and look
something like this this pyramid also
has dimensions of an X with a Y depth
and a Z over 2 height so it's volume
would be this as well now what is the
combined volume of these two pyramids
well it's just going to be this times 2
so the combined volume of these pyramids
and let me just draw it that way so
these two pyramids that look something
like this I'm going to try to color code
it we have two of them so two times
their volume is going to be equal to
well two times this is just going to be
K times X Y Z K x y and z and we have
more pyramids to deal with for example I
have this pyramid right over here where
this face is its base and then if I try
to draw the pyramid it looks something
like this this one right over there now
what is its volume going to be its
volume is going to be equal to
k times its base is y times Z so K Y Z
and what's its height well its height is
going to be half of X so this height
right over here is half of X so it's K
times y times Z times X over 2 or I
could say times X and then divide
everything by 2 now I have another
pyramid that has the exact same
dimensions this one over here if I try
to draw it on the other face opposite
the one we just saw essentially if we
just flip this one over has the exact
same dimensions so one way to think
about it we have two pyramids that look
like that with those types of dimensions
this is for an arbitrary rectangular
prism that we are dealing with so I have
two of these and so if you have two of
their volumes what's it going to be it's
just going to be two times this
expression so it's going to be K times X
Y Z X Y Z interesting and then last but
not least we have two more pyramids we
have this one that has a face that has
the base right over here that's its base
and if it was transparent you'd be able
to see where I'm drawing right here and
then you have one on the opposite side
right over there on the other side and
you like you to say if you were to flip
this around and so by the exact same
argument so let me just draw it so we
have two of these two of these pyramids
my best to draw it so times two so each
of them would have a volume of what each
of them their base is x times Z so it's
going to be K times X times Z that's the
area of their base and then what is
their height well each of them has a
height of Y over 2 so times y over 2 and
I have two of those pyramids so I'm
going to multiply those by 2 the twos
cancel out so I'm just left with K times
X Y Z so K times X Y Z now one of the
interesting things that we've just
stumbled on in this
seeing that even though these pyramids
have different dimensions and look
different they all have actually the
same volume which is interesting in and
of themselves and so if we were to add
up the volumes of all of the pyramids
here and use this formula to express
them to her to add all of them together
that should be equal to the volume of
the entire rectangular prism and then
maybe we can figure out K so the volume
of the entire rectangular prism is X Y Z
X times y times Z and then that's got to
be equal to the sum of these so that's
going to be equal to K X Y Z plus K X Y
Z plus K X Y Z or you could say that's
going to be equal to 3 K X Y Z all I did
I said let me just add up the volume
from all of these pyramids and so what
do we get for K well we could divide
both sides by 3 X Y Z to solve for K 3 X
Y Z 3 X Y Z and we are left with on the
right hand side the everything cancels
out we're just left with a K and on the
left hand side we're left with a 1/3 and
so we get K is equal to 1/3 K is equal
to 1/3 and there you have it that's our
argument for why the volume of a pyramid
is 1/3 times the dimensions of the base
times the height so you might see it
written that way or you might see it
written as 1/3 times base and so if x
times y is the base so the area of the
base so the base area times the height
which in this case is Z but if you say H
for that you might see the formula for a
pyramid written this way as well but
they are equivalent but that's why you
should feel good about the 1/3 part